former senior adviser to the trump
campaign laura trump all right before i
get to this
i have a lot of friends in north
carolina i mean a lot of friends you're
you were born and raised in north
carolina now
your name keeps coming up as a potential
senate candidate
for this seat that is now open for 2022
are you considering possibly running
yeah well i absolutely am and look north
carolina
is not just my home state it's my home
it's where all my family lives it's
really the state that made me the woman
i am today and
nothing would be a bigger honor for me
than to represent the people
of my home and my home state and
it's something i'm taking really
seriously sean you know i get asked
about it a lot and
i've really been so flattered by so many
of these polls that have come out
but really we've been through a lot as a
family over the past not just year but
really past five years so i think really
we're kind of taking a step back
really assessing things taking it very
seriously but
you know i'm taking a little time to
spend with my kids with my husband
um and and i will make a decision on it
but i
i certainly am considering it and again
nothing would be a greater honor for me
than to represent the people of my home
state all right i do
i hate to buy i am doing my job uh but
you know what it's a thoughtful answer
uh you know there were a lot of i
believers out there we watched
justice kavanaugh broken on national
television
pretty much broken i that's that's how i
would describe it
and we know that there were charges and
allegations made i said at the time
that i believe in due process and the
presumption of innocence i believe that
today and that applies to democrats that
applies to andrew cuomo
but all the i believers are what i call
the i believer caucus it was led by
kamala harris and the silence is now
deafening from most of those people a
few have kind of been shamed into coming
out maybe a few were sincere
and are consistent but not the majority
let's talk about this double standard
and
what they did to kavanaugh and then look
at what happened in the case of the
allegations of julie swetnick
you know against kavanaugh and they
became debunked pretty quick
but yet his family was dragged through
hell
yeah well it was an absolutely
disgusting thing to see and by the way
i agree with you i believe in due
process i believe that in america
it states that people are innocent until
proven guilty and we should
let governor andrew cuomo of course have
his day in court
let's let this all play out but with
that said i'm old enough to remember
sean when
kamala harris herself called for an fbi
investigation
against brett kavanaugh and the charges
against him
were not nearly as credible as these
charges against andrew cuomo at least
they they were you know the cuomo
allegations are in the same
past couple decades um but really i
think
it's been sort of obvious to people to
watch this happen and we shouldn't be
surprised because after all it was
kamala harris herself
who after calling joe biden a racist on
stage
had no problem turning back around a
couple of months later
and being his running mate and now vice
president of the united states to him
but she when she was questioned about
that said well it's just all politics
this is all politics for these people
they don't really care about americans
in fact one of the the women
who has accused governor cuomo i think
worked on the biden harris campaign
they don't care about her you said it in
your open it is
all about power for these people but it
was disgusting to see
the way brett kavanaugh was treated
every single person in america
should have their day in court should
have due process and look we'll see what
happens with
governor cuomo it's sad because it's
such an important real
and real issue and it's only used to as
a political weapon to bludgeon political
opponents
which i you know it's it's sad to see
this
cuomo himself though was an i believer
cuomo said i believe cuomo wanted
at the time brett kavanaugh to take a
lie detector test
shouldn't the same standards that he
applied to kavanaugh apply to him
well if he if he himself said it i don't
know why he would have a problem doing
that
um but this is the problem whenever you
make a blanket statement like
believe all women it doesn't give the
space for again due process it doesn't
give
any credibility to anybody at all
whenever they say wait a minute this
this didn't really happen
well we should let a process play out
but
it's really i i think it's really kind
of it's it's sad to see the way it's all
turned back around on people but when
you say
things like believe all women and then
women come after you or women come after
people in your own party
and you are silent on it shame on you
that should never happen
in the united states of america all
right laura trump big news for you
tonight and i'm sure the people of north
carolina
um the ones are asking me i got you your
answer
got that off my my chest all right thank
you